hello everyone
so thanks for tuning in so i'm going to
speak on uniform brackets containers
and combinatorial macbeth regions so
this is work in collaboration with
arijit kosh from the indian statistical
institute
and shea moran from technion and google
research
so it's a tale of three structures
firstly we have containers from the area
of online and distributed learning
theory
then we have combinatorial macbeth
regions or m nets from computational
geometry
and finally we have uniform brackets
which sort of unify both the previous
notions
from empirical processes and statistical
learning
theory so containers were recently
proposed by braverman called moran and
saxena
[Music]
the idea is that let's say you have a
probability space which has a ground set
x
and a measure mu
and you have a family of measurable
sets that you are interested in
and a parameter
epsilon now you want to approximate your
family h
by another family c
such that for all f
which are member of your first family
there is
a member g in the second family
such that f is contained in g
and the measure of the difference of
these two sets is at most epsilon
right so then we say that the second
family c is an epsilon container for h
with respect to the measure mu
so breibermann and al were actually
interested in the case where x is a set
of endpoints in rd
and
the family h
is
all possible subsets of x which can be
generated as intersections of x with
half spaces in rd
and the measure mu is just the empirical
measure or the counting measure
so
um
what they showed was
that for any epsilon in zero and one
this family has an epsilon container of
size
at most order of d by epsilon to the d
now in fact you can forget about mu
so you can say that this is in fact a
distribution free
bound
so this notion was inspired by
containers for independent sets in
hypergraphs
which has led to a lot of
progress in extreme recombinatorics and
hypergraph theory in the last decade or
so
and
bravermanital
proved they're bound using a new dual
form of character dory's theorem
and this led to improved protocols for
bonding the communication complexity of
distributed learning problems such as
learning of half spaces and linear
programming
okay so let's move on
to some discrete geometry
um
we have this beautiful theorem of
macbeth let's say we have
a convex body
in t-dimensional space
then
this theorem says that you can get a
collection of subsets of the convex body
such that suppose you have a parameter
epsilon
then any half space which
intersects the convex body in at least
an epsilon fraction of the
volume of the body
there must be a member of this
collection which is lying completely
inside the intersection
okay and the volume of this member is at
least a constant
fraction of the volume of the
intersection
where this constant doesn't depend on
the convex body or
um
on epsilon or on the half space at all
right
so this is the theorem of my peace
and it was proposed in 1952 and since
then it has become classical theorem in
convex geometry
and
so these
collection of subsets these subsets are
called macbeth regions
and this theorem has found applications
and variants
in discrete and computational geometry
so it was natural to think of a
combinatorial analog of mcbeats regions
and this was proposed by mustafa and ray
in 2014
what they said was so putting it again
into this probability theoretic
framework let's say you have a property
space
and you have a collection of subsets
that you are interested in
and two parameters lambda and epsilon in
zero and one
so we want to approximate h by another
family m
such that for any member f in the first
family which has
measure at least epsilon there exists a
member of the second family which is
completely contained in f
and the measure of this
uh
member of the second family is at least
an epsilon is at least a lambda fraction
of the measure of f
then we say that m the second family is
a lambda heavy epsilon
m net for the first family h
right so
mustafa and ray proved upper bounds for
the size of
epsilon nets
for several geometrically defined
systems
and the results were later generalized
by
kosh
who proved that
given any epsilon
you can find
epsilon m net for set systems that are
semi algebraic and also have vc
dimension at most d
for some fixed lambda so these are
lambda heavy for some fixed lambda
and typically lambda
is
less than half but it could be as bad as
1 by d to the order of d
so we saw two of the definitions now
let's move on
to uniform brackets which come from
empirical processes
and learning theory
so here we have again a probability
space and a family of measurable sets
and parameter epsilon
and we want to
approximate our family h
by another family b
here the condition is that for every
member f in h
there exists two members a and g in b
such that a is contained in f and
g contains f
and
the measure of the difference of g and a
is at most epsilon
so if such a family exists then we say
that
this b
is
an epsilon uniform bracket
for h
so the epsilon bracketing number
is just the minimum size of an epsilon
bracket for age
and the bracketing entropy is the
logarithm of the bracketing number
so it was natural to ask what is the
most general condition for a set system
to have a bounded bracketing number or
container family
and you can see that this is not the
bounded vc dimension
because of um
result of one handle which says that
there exists
set systems of vc dimension 2 and yet
having unbounded bracketing number so
bracketing number is
a
strictly stronger condition than we see
dimension
um
so this is a fundamental
um
notion in empirical processes and
statistical learning
because it gives
if you have bounded bracketing number
you can get simpler
and more robust proofs of
very important
properties like strong law of net
of large numbers
and as well as uniform convergence
properties
and these proofs do not require
techniques like symmetrization or
assumptions like iid sampling and so on
so
that's why
uniform brackets or bounded bracketing
number is a fundamental
notion in empirical processes
uh so very recently it has been used
uh in
the smooth analysis of online
and differentially private learning
algorithms by have the lab rough garden
so there are some connections uh that
are relatively
obvious
between brackets containers and m nets
um
so if you have a silent uniform brackets
clearly you have epsilon containers
and also you have one minus order of
epsilon heavy eminence
right
so
this direction is clear that brackets
are stronger than containers as well as
eminence
also if you have m nets
and you have containers then you should
have brackets in
intuitively this should hold
but we need that lambda should be very
large should be close to one
but
as we saw in the proofs of
um
lambda can be
pretty bad
and it's definitely less than half
so there is a third point which is that
if we are looking at the
specific case of points and half spaces
in the dimensional space
then
notice that the complement of a half
space is also a half space
so let's say you have a
set
in your
set system
in your collection f
so this is a half space
and the complement is also defined using
a half space
so you have a container cf for your
set f
right now since the con complement is a
half space you have a
container for the complement as well
now if you look at the complement of
this container the container for the
complement set
fc
then this
a complement
is contained in the original set f
right
which means that you can take
the family of containers
and the family of complements of
containers and this will give you
a two epsilon bracket
for
the original
family of points and half spaces
or you can think that epsilon by two
containers will give you epsilon
brackets
okay so with all these
observations
what are the new results
so the first uh result is that you don't
need m nets as well as containers
to get
uniform brackets you just need one of
these
and you need that they should hold for
both the family as well as the
compliment family so here the compliment
family is
take each member of your family
and
complement it with respect to the ground
set
okay so on route to proving this
equivalence theorem we got
several uh
other results
like
m nets
uh if you have them for a fixed epsilon
naught
and fixed lambda naught then you can get
m net for all epsilon and lambda
and also
if you have m nets for a family
then you can get containers
for the complement family and vice versa
so with
using this equivalence theorem
we were able to port
the bounds and the known bounds on m
nets
to the case of containers
and
um
uniform brackets
right so this gives us improvements
in distribution free
bracketing number
bounds for different
set systems so in particular for the
system of points and half spaces we get
a bound of
one by epsilon to the order of d
so this is a d dimensional space
and more generally for semi algebraic
systems we get again one by silent to
the order of d
but here d remember is the vc dimension
so we also get lower bounds
on
these
systems
so
in fact for points and half spaces we
show that you cannot do much better than
one by epsilon
to the
d by three
so there are
um
there are there are um sets of endpoints
such that
there is no um
there is no m net or
there is no uniform bracket of size
uh less than one by epsilon to the d by
three
and similarly for points and hyperplanes
you can get a lower bound of one by
epsilon to the d
so we have constructive lower bounds now
and as a result of uh improving the
upper bounds actually
we get uh
improvements in the results of um
braverman at al as well as hotlap at l
so in uh for example we show that the
communication complexity of learning
half spaces
is order of d log n
and the communication complexity of
learning convex disjointness is order of
d square log n
and
again now if we look at
the
smooth analysis of online learning
algorithms
uh then again we get improvements in the
bracketing numbers
so this is
let's say you have the class of degree d
polynomial threshold functions in rn
we can show that this class has
bracketing number which is at most one
by epsilon to the order of n by d
and similarly if you take the class of k
polytubes
you can get one by epsilon to the order
of nk
right and these are improvements on
these previous parts so previously we
had one
instead of one by epsilon we had n to
the d by epsilon in the first bound
and in the second one we had n k by
epsilon
okay so
now these improvements
in the bracketing number
give you also improvements um
in regret bounds for the smooth analysis
of online
learning algorithms against adaptive
sigma smooth adversaries
so i will just let you read these uh
bounds so in particular you can observe
that this
log factor
log of the vc dimension
has been removed from the upper bound
and this is true for both these classes
b and d as well as q and k
so here again we had log of the vc
dimension
this has been removed from the upper
bound
okay so here's some high-level proof
ideas
so the idea is
we will proceed in the direction of
assuming
that the complement set system has
eminence and trying to prove that uh
this implies epsilon containers for the
original set system
so there are two parts to the proof the
first is we get epsilon containers
for sets whose measure is close to
epsilon so these are the small sets
and the second part we use these small
set containers to get epsilon containers
for the entire set system
okay so let's take
a member f in the family h
and
let's see how we are going to get
a container for f
so the idea here is we are going to
extract large chunk from the complement
of f
we are going to do this recursively so
every time we keep doing this right so
now you can see that
the measure of the complement of f has
gone down by a lot
so we keep doing this delete and recurse
idea
until the measure of the complement goes
below epsilon
and so the only question that
remains is how do we get a large chunk
in each round
so we want a large chunk from the
complement
and the answer is of course that we will
be using our assumption
that the complement set system has
m nets
so let's say we take
a lambda heavy epsilon by 2 m net
for the complement system and this m net
has
some sets uh which are m1 to mr
so for each
eye what we are going to do is we are
going to recurse on this
uh reduced system so we delete the
points in mi
then we look at the reduced set system
and
we keep doing this uh so every at every
step we branch
uh on the size of the epsilon on the
size of the m net
and
we do this recursion step until the
measure of the complement becomes at
most epsilon
right so we get a recursion tree
where the branching factor will be
controlled by the size of the m net that
we are getting right
and for each leaf level node of this
tree
once we reach a leaf level node we are
just going to add it to
the container set
right so in one step what is the
reduction that we get
so suppose you started with a
family
which had measure mu i
or rather mu of uh
f5 complement
then
what you can show is that the reduction
that you get will be at least
something like 1 minus
lambda by 2.
so this is by assuming that
the
the complement set
has measure
at least half
right
so what is the maximum number of
recursion steps that we need to go
so this is controlled by saying that
we want
the final
measure
of the universe or of the complement set
to be at most epsilon right
so this gives that the maximum number of
levels that you go in your recursion
tree
is going to be something like or
order of log 1 by epsilon divided by log
1 minus lambda by 2
right so what is the size of the
container family that we get so it's the
branching factor
raised to the number of
levels right so the branching factor is
like one by epsilon to the d
then we get epsilon
to the minus log one by epsilon
so this is much worse than the lower
bounds and
um
also the previous uh
bound for points and half spaces
because there is a log one by epsilon in
the exponent
right
so
but if we have that
the original set f had small measure
then this is good
so why is that so it's because let's
look at the ratio of uh the complement
to the
entire system
so it's going to be
this
uh
the mu of uh
the complement of the set so this is at
least epsilon
so this is again at least epsilon
and this note that this is at least
is around epsilon by our assumption
right so we can show that this ratio is
at least half always
so at each step we can take a half a net
right
and now
the size of the container family would
be like instead of one by epsilon to the
d it will be like two to the d
and
now we can control the final size that
we get
so it's polynomial in one website
and now we come to the second part so
here
we want to remove this
log one by epsilon that we were getting
earlier in the exponent
so the idea is that
we'll use delta coverings of set systems
so what is a delta cover it's a subset
of
the
family that we are looking at
such that for every member f in the
family there exists a member in this
subset
such that the measure of the symmetric
difference is at most delta
so if we think of our
sets in the family
as characteristic vectors
then here's a typical
family
represented in the hamming space
or the hemi metric
and now when we are taking this
delta cover basically we are saying
choose a point
and you cannot choose anything that lies
in this delta radius of
this point
right so
and further
you're saying that
um
every point in the original family
lies in this delta ball of
some point in the delta cover that's why
it's called the cover
so housler approved this bound
in 1995 what he said was
that if you have take any set system
with bounded vc dimension
and any delta then
the set system will have a delta
covering of size order of
1 by delta raised to d
so observe that we are basically looking
at the space of characteristic vectors
offsets
in the set system with respect to
the hamming metric
so our goal now
in order to get containers
while minimal coverings
our goal will be
to get
one minus order epsilon
heavy m net for the container family
for the complement family sorry
uh so let's take a minimal delta
covering
now for each set in the complement
family
uh for a fixed stat in the complement
family let p
be the nearest neighbor of this set
and now using a little bit of set theory
what you can show is
that if
you take two sets two subsets
and they have
small
um
symmetric difference this difference has
small measure
then
the intersection will have large measure
right
so if we condition on this nearest
neighbor p
we we get that the conditional measure
which is like
the the measure of the
intersection divided by the measure of p
if this is large
since
this is large since
we know that
p is the nearest neighbor of f
complement so that uh the symmetric
so that um
the measure of the intersection is large
right and
so we can also say that the measure of
the original set f
in this conditional space will be small
right
so now
[Music]
suppose we look at all those
uh members f whose nearest neighbor was
b
so we have these sets f f f three now
look at the complement sets
right all of them are very small
so what we are saying is all these small
complements can be actually captured
by an epsilon container cp
right
so we have an epsilon container
which will contain
each of these complements
which have small measure
and we can do this because we already
have a bound on epsilon containers for
sets of small measure right
and
note that the complement family of this
container
is a one minus order of epsilon heavy m
net
for
the set of
uh
the the collection of uh sets in the
complement system
whose nearest neighbor was b
right
so now remember remember that this was
our goal initially like we said that
we want a one minus order epsilon heavy
m net
right so now
we have such an m net but only for the
sets whose nearest neighbor was b
so we just need to take the union of all
these families over all b
in the pack in the covering
and this will give us a one minus order
epsilon heavy m net
for the complement family
so what is the size of
um
so um
once we take the complement of this
heavy m net
this will be a
an epsilon container
for the original family right so we have
an epsilon container for the original
family now
uh we just need to compute the size so
the size is just the number of members
of the covering b
times the size of the container family
for each member
so we already showed that the size of
the container family is like order of
one by epsilon to the d
and the number of container families is
also not
very large it is
you can choose delta
so that is
the number of
of p
become of the order of one by
epsilon to the d at most
so this gives you that the total size
will be like one by epsilon to the order
of t
so with this i conclude
thank you for listening
and
i will be happy to answer any questions